the following is a paid promotion for
afk arena
[Music]
do you have any idea what you've gotten
yourself into
do you even know what's coming for you
i think you will i keep hearing these
voices in my head that say
there's a link in the description i
don't know what that means
i don't know what the description is
okay but there's a link there
i just need to find it who do you think
you are
you don't even know me you don't even
know yourself i don't even know myself
so how can you know me
if i don't know me then who do you know
that i am
and you know you are what does it mean
what does the link in the description
mean why wouldn't anybody tell me
why aren't you talking to me it's fun
that's what i don't get the game is fun
and i'm gonna be in it i go to bed i
wake up there's more gold
i go to work i come back there's more
gold
there's always more what kind of game
business
you don't understand you're not the one
that's gonna be in there
i'm gonna be in there with them they're
fighting all the time
i'm human i'm still just human
if i'm gonna be a hero i'm gonna make
sure that my mind and my body is up to
snuff
because these guys and gals and
creatures
they fight non-stop they just keep going
for what some cause honor
i don't know but if i'm gonna be in
there with him
i'm gonna prove my worth it's an entire
world that fits in the palm of your hand
you can put it on any mobile device and
play it whenever you have time and if
you don't
it'll keep going without you what would
you call that
i just don't know who i am anymore
am i the me that's here or am i the me
in the game
what are you doing why are you better
than me what do i need to do
what do i need to do to be a hero i'm
gonna be in the game
but no one's telling you what to do it's
free the link's in the description
what do these things mean what do they
mean and if i'm gonna be in the game
do i even have a choice they keep
pushing me they keep telling me things
that i already know
they keep making me think that i'm crazy
there's only so much
i can take before i snapped i can't keep
running forever
they're going to find me someday
maybe i'll find them no
it can't be looking for me
or should i say looking for yourself
hi you know when i first told afk arena
that i was going to be making a fake
movie trailer to promote their game
they were confused and i told them
what better what better way for people
to understand how fun your game is
than me making a trailer that absolutely
has
nothing to do with the game at all and
it's just my excuse
because i like making fake movie
trailers and you know bless them they
believed me
so here i am they don't even know about
this i'm adding this on to the end of
the video after they've already approved
the trailer
i'm adding this on i just want to say
this game is actually good
legitimately it's good if you haven't
played it before i
immensely recommend it when they first
approached me for this deal i downloaded
it to check it out obviously i wasn't
going to promote something that i'd
never played before so i downloaded it
to check it out
and my god i was immediately addicted to
it
not a joke it was the first thing that i
checked every morning
uh it plays itself but also there's a
ton of stuff to do that's what they
didn't say
um it collects rewards for you when
you're not playing so you get them when
you come back in but i
i never left it so i would just wait for
the rewards
to get there and click on it and then
keep going forward uh
it's legitimately good i've played a lot
of mobile games in my time and this is
not something i'm being paid
to say i never do things where i'm paid
to say that something's good if i don't
think it's good
this game is actually good so i highly
recommend it it's free
you can download it through the link in
the description below you can go to the
app store and just type in afk arena and
find it for yourself
but i highly recommend that you use my
link so that they can actually believe
that my trailer did do good
right guys it did good it made sense you
were convinced
you were convinced that how good the
game was by my trailer
you it worked right please come on keep
this between us download the game
and then say man markiplier's trailer
really convinced me that this game was
good stuff
please i i need this they'll never i'll
never get a sponsorship again
they have to believe that this please
i'm begging you please i would never i
would never
i'd never lead a company astray
with my weird ideas right
link in the description which is down
there or
in here